it's commentary time again I'm sorry to
be doing so many of these but we're
actually busy filming the beat two year
anniversary so you'll still see new
nostalgia critics you might be getting a
lot more commentaries as well so and
this is gonna be very surreal this is
the sort of the first official nostalgia
critic review the first one I ever did
was the Transformers new movie the newer
movie that came out and that was much
more like a bum review really this is
the first official review I did of
something nostalgic and yeah actually is
any of that outfit I think the jacket is
the only thing I still have and even
animate be whatever sewing off soon
because the hem the back is really
coming off and starting to really fall
apart
this is back before I knew where to look
for something apparently I'm watching
this on the side of the screen drugs are
the dope that okay I could do
impressions that's the whole thing and
because this was on YouTube that's when
I used to where I used to post these it
they're very very short so they're only
like you know whatever is there under 10
minutes and the interesting thing is
that this one really does flow a little
bit more like a review of the first
couple do we just pop a good thing at a
bad thing it's sort of a bad thing cuz
you miss out on a lot of jokes and you
don't quite get the feel of the weight
loss Xpression you don't quite get the
feel of the of the movie or the special
sometimes you know we just go through
the whole thing you can get the idea of
what I'm going through and that's what
the viewer will be going through
watching it
also keep mine this is when I was trying
to figure out what's a funny kind of
yelling so when I scream here that just
means today am much III don't do my high
page voices I didn't know if that was
gonna be funny and then I found out over
time yesterday you know that does get a
bigger laugh because it sounds more
pathetic you know and desperate so here
I do sort of a realistic voice a
realistic scream and it sounds more
threatening than it does funny and it
really doesn't work so again just
interesting the contrast between then
and now also the like look at that
lighting I had no lighting in that room
all that I had was whatever the the
ceiling lamp and that was it yeah was is
screaming that screaming is so
restrained and it's so held back it's
actually sort of hard to watch hey see
that sounds real that sounds like I'm
about to kill somebody but not in a
funny way
you know a lot of it has to come from
the fact that I'm scared or I'm afraid
of something it can't come from as much
that I'm angry I mean even though a lot
of times I seem very angry it's a lot of
it's coming out of frustration and fear
and stuff like that the more pathetic it
sounds the more humorous it is so if it
sounds like I'm really taking it
seriously
it's not funny but it sounds like it's a
really pathetic kind of fear then it is
yours you know what is half that stuff I
can't remember I think my brother
watched this with me but I don't think
he was officially like riding with me
yeah you know everyone wants a while you
throw out a joke and now he watches
everything with me pretty much love
George sees got hate to see him in this
and this this is what I knew this is
gonna be funny when I could do that dub
successfully the the patent dub oh
that's from Garfield Christmas by the
way I because there's no good clips of
Garfield saying anything in this and
there's no good clothes of anyone saying
anything really I joke never quite
worked I hate I really thought that was
gonna be funnier but for some reason
dude maybe you shoulda held him myself a
little longer so I don't know but again
it's such an interesting learning
process doing this cuz this really did
just start off as a hobby you know just
I had the fighting and movies were
bigoted on YouTube I wanted to see if I
was still funny I think I did a sketch
before this and then I want to do a
character and the rest is history as
they say oh this song is are out there
with ducktales I won't leave your head I
shut the fuck up this song I hate this
song first use of the gun I can't
believe I've been using that gun for so
long it's just a pellet gun you know it
with the orange tip painted black I used
it for the Cheerios to sketch and I just
been using it ever since there's
something so menacing funny also sort of
pathetic and about a gun IV it's just
the fastest guy would carry a gun around
all the time just such insecurity yeah
look at that I'm wearing a watch does
anyone wear a watch anymore I mean we
all have cell phones there's just no
point in having a washer and the
actually going over the story and
everything is over now it's just looking
back and talking about stuffing there's
still a few minutes of it left it's it's
very very interesting
see here I wouldn't just say people cry
it would actually show how many times
they cry so I give people a good idea
about what the special is like and how
often it happens and the more you feel
like you're in the viewer seat while
watching this and you're you're almost
participating the voicing the opinion or
if my opinion matches yours while you're
watching it the more you can laugh at it
usually the better this came across
pretty good though yeah they just they
could hammer it in or again yell here is
very reserved
see it's it's very held bag like I
sounds still trying to figure out what
was funny of what was and I really
thought that if I went all out it would
look you know more it's pathetic you
know but in a bad way like you know
amazing that's way too seriously but no
it's actually pretty humorous as long as
it shows that I'm really afraid of this
you know and not having a good time but
it doesn't like rule my life or anything
you know I think people can enjoy it in
this whole timer time Barbara talk
j-just so it looks really oh I could eat
your hair Oh giant jelly doughnut yeah
okay that's like the worst Bush this
bong I made at the ended there that's
practical whatever this is it's just I
think I have like a cop and a beaker and
I don't know what the hell it is I don't
think you can make a bong out of it but
so there it is that YouTube channel
doesn't exist anymore close this out
Simon